divide and Express as a simplified
rational expression so we have one
rational expression being divided by
another rational expression and once
again rational expressions you can
really just view them as fractions and
when you divide by a fraction that's the
same thing as multiplying by its inverse
so this expression right over here this
is the same thing as 2p plus 6 over P
plus 5 I just rewrote this over here
times the inverse of this right over
here so times 4p plus 20 over 10 and
multiplying rational expressions or
multiplying fractions pretty
straightforward you just multiply the
numerators and you just multiply the
denominators so the numerator over here
is going to be 2p plus 6 times 4p plus
20 and the denominator over here is
going to be P plus 5p plus 5 times 10 so
we've done the first part we've divided
the two which is essentially multiplying
by the inverse of this and now we want
to simplify it so to simplify one of
these terms are probably going to cancel
out with some of these so let's let's
see if we can simplify these terms up
here so 2p plus 6 we can factor a 2 out
we can rewrite 2p plus 6 if we factor 2
out as 2 times P plus 3 that's this term
right over here and then 4p plus 20 both
4p and 20 are divisible by 4 so we can
factor 4 out so times 4 times P plus 5
times P plus 5 and then in the
denominator in the denominator we just
have a 10 times P plus 5 we just have a
10 we do that in that same go to the
pink 10 times P plus 5 so we can already
start to cancel out a little bit both
the numerator and the denominator have
something that's a multiple of 2 we can
divide the numerator by 2 and this will
become 1 divide the denominator by 2 and
this becomes 5 and then we can also
divide the numerator and the denominator
by P plus 5 assuming that they're not
equal to 0 assuming that the expression
is not equal
zero or that P does not equal negative
five so if we divide the numerator
denominator by P plus five these guys
cancel out and then we are left with in
our numerator we have four times P plus
three so we are left with four times P
plus 3 P plus three and in the
denominator we are left with we are left
with just a 5 we are left with just a 5
and I've said this in previous videos
but if you're truly if you truly want
this expression right over here to be
100% equivalent to this expression right
over here you all you do have to make
the assumption you do have to make the
assumption that P is not defined at
negative 5 because if if you look at
either well 1 if you look at this
expression right over here actually
either of these expressions are not
defined when P is equal to negative 5 so
over here you have to put the constraint
that P so domain the domain is all real
numbers
all real numbers except except P is
equal to negative 5 or another way to
say it is you could put any value for P
here and you'll get a defined answer
except if P equals negative 5 because
then this is 2 being divided by 0 and
then this is being divided by 0 so if
you really want this expression to be
completely 100% identical to this
expression you have to put the same
constraint you could say you have to say
not defined not defined at P is equal to
negative 5 which is another way of
saying that the domain is not defined
there or you could also write the domain
here is all real numbers for P except
for P equals negative 5